merci merci jean pierre bonjour à tous
alors moi je vais vous parler sécurité
ou plutôt je vais pas vous en parler
je vais vous dire ce que l'on va faire
parce que j'entendais un premier
ministre à la radio quand je revenais je
venais pour vous retrouver ou à la radio
on nous disait qu'il voulait se redonner
une image autoritaire s'il a besoin de
se donner cette image l'autorité a c'est
que précisément si jamais un jour il l'a
eu en tout cas il ne l'a plus et que on
peut vérifier la différence entre les
paroles et les actes
et notamment en ile-de-france région
capitale région de 12 millions
d'habitants et qui malheureusement est
victime de ce fléau de l'insécurité les
actes nous les avons et nous les
connaissons depuis 17 ans sous la
présidence de jean paul huchon président
socialiste lui même est kidnappé par ces
soi-disant alliés écologistes et qui
pratique depuis 17 ans une politique
totalement idéologues anti sécuritaire
anti sécurité totalement laxiste puisque
quelques chiffres sur un budget de 12
milliards d'euros en ile de france
seulement quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros sont consacrés à
l'investissement
quant à l'airé pécresse interroge la
région ile de france
interroge l'exécutif de gauche sur la
région est de la région ile-de-france
sur les raisons de cette absence
d'investissement de la région en matière
de sécurité la réponse est simple c'est
pas notre boulot on nous répond ce n'est
pas notre boulot
moi je vais vous dire la région à quel
niveau elle peut être utile notamment en
matière de sécurité c'est la sécurité
évidemment des lycées c'est la sécurité
des transports
mais c'est aussi la sécurité des
artisans et nos commerçants j'ai bien
compris qu'il y avait beaucoup de
représentants des zones rurales et tous
les artisans et commerçants vous dise
quoi nous sommes braquer nous avons peur
nous avons peur que nous retirons notre
caisse le soir et que nous la ramenons
nous avons des propositions très
précises en la matière qui sont
notamment par exemple que la région
ile-de-france aide et cofinance avec les
artisans et les commerçants
cette capacitéà vidéo protéger leur leur
commerce
c'était évidemment la même chose dans
les trains quand vous entendez mai
déjà le cas c'est déjà possible vous
avez les nouveaux transilien qui sont
qui sont équipés c'est faux deux trains
sur trois deux transiliens sur trois ne
sont pas équipées de vidéoprotection et
pour une raison simple c'est juste une
question d'idéologie d'absence totale de
volonté politique d'installer la
vidéoprotection dans les trains quand on
x et ce sont pour des raisons techniques
évidemment que tous les industriels vous
disent que ce n'est pas le cas et c'est
simplement une question de volonté
d'engager le budget nécessaire et
valérie pécresse en cette matière a fait
partie des premiers à dire on va pas
juste vous faire des grandes promesses
sur 10 15 20 ou 30 ans pour que ce soit
effective dès le départ on va débloquer
donc une enveloppe financière
conséquente en matière d'installation de
vidéoprotection déjà dans toutes les
premières rames de chaque train de
manière à ce que dès 2021 c'est-à-dire
dans un temps très restreint nous ayons
la totalité des rames qui soient
équipées de vidéoprotection
s'agissant des lycées il y a évidemment
des parents qui sont qui sont dans la
salle malheureusement nous avons été
beaucoup à vivre soit nous mêmes soit
via nos enfants des situations de racket
des situations d'agressions des
situations et c'est malheureusement le
cas toujours de trafic de drogue
quelle est la meilleure qu'elle est la
meilleure façon d'éviter ces trafics de
l'est de les prévenir
c'est précisément là encore cette vidéo
protection c'est également la mise en
place de grilles celle également le fait
de renforcer au sein des lycées
ces personnalités qui seront chargés de
la sécurité des lycées là encore ce
n'est absolument pas un faisable
c'est juste une question de volonté
politique je pense que nous sommes ici
dans un conseil national à l'occasion
d'élections régionales
on a souvent dit que les élections et
que les régions et l apo créer et
préparer les laboratoires de la
politique nationale de demain
nous avons vu ce que ça donnait avec les
la quasi totalité des régions qui
étaient de gauche et on a vu ce que ça
donnait aujourd'hui avec françois
hollande à la présidence de la
république
nous vous demandons de nous aider à
inverser et à changer radicalement
toutes les options qui sont prises la
sécurité est un des éléments mal
joueur de ses différents programmes avec
nicolas sarkozy président des
républicains nous sommes en vain nous
n'avons absolument pas à rougir
justement de ce qui a été fait en
matière de sécurité puisque je crois que
c'est sinon le meilleur l'un des
meilleurs ministres de l'intérieur que
nous ayons jamais eu
et qu'il a fait la preuve aussi que
justement en prenant des mesures justes
des mesures concrètes et des mesures
financées nous avons des résultats car
quand la droite était au pouvoir
quand nicolas sarkozy était ministre de
l'intérieur la sécurité n'est plus passé
n'était plus le premier sujet de
préoccupation des français tout
simplement parce que la question était
en train d'être réglé c'est ce que nous
allons recommencer à faire à travers les
régions à travers les outils que nous
allons mettre en place localement et de
proximité
et puis de placer la rampe de lancement
pour 2017
nous vous attendons tous au rendez vous
en tout cas nous sommes déjà sur le
terrain nous vous attendons avec vous et
demain c'est la victoire